et si la danse après la course à pied
évidemment et si la danse était le
meilleur des sports on s'intéresse ce
soir un loisir pratiqué par des milliers
d'adeptes en France il y a le plaisir du
spectacle des costumes et la variété des
styles salsa valse tango exemple
récemment à la salle l'escale de
Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire avec plus de 160
danseurs de la France entière en
compétition Aurélie Renaud
la samba puis la bossa nova des danses
lacives mérite mais qui n'empêche pas à
Joël et son mari de suivre les pas à 70
ans passés ils sont les doyens de la
compétition la danse c'est pour eux une
cure de jouvence et puis ça permet de
garder la mémoire ça permet de garder le
mouvement ça permet de garder tous les
enchaînements donc c'est quand même un
travail mental il faut retenir les
chorégraphies mais pas que il faut aussi
discipliner son corps à prendre la
technique
175 danseurs venus de la France entière
et une passion commune pour les danses
standard comme la valse ou les latines
le jail ou encore le chacha un moyen de
se glisser dans un personnage Céline en
robe dorée et cadre dans l'informatique
dans la vie plutôt discrète et en fait
la danse permet de justement s'exprimer
à travers un personnage et c'est ce qui
fait le plaisir de la danse en
Indre-et-Loire beaucoup de cours de
danse mais peu de compétition le
troisième Grand Prix de
Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire donne l'occasion aux
participants de se défier devant les
juges question y a-t-il une danse
particulièrement difficile il y a
quelques danses qui sont réputées pour
être un petit peu plus compliqué
notamment le slow Fox la valse lente qui
voilà qui n'est pas simple les costumes
la musique la variété des danses dans le
public les amateurs se régale ben on est
admiratif parce que on danse pas aussi
bien que certains et on voudrait faire
encore mieux que avec certains à très
haut niveau on voit un côté aérien on a
l'impression que c'est facile en réalité
ça ne l'est pas quoi au fil de la
journée le parquet se vide car ce grand
spectacle est avant tout une compétition
c'est un sport de comparaison pour
l'instant le premier critère du jugement
c'est la musique après vous allez
pouvoir regarder la chorégraphie la
tenue du corps
la clé du succès l'entraînement les
amateurs danse ici minimum 4 heures par
semaine